I grew up in suburbia,
Salt Lake City,
Utah for the most part just right
outside of salt lake.
Um,
I'm the oldest of six,
kind of a very typical mormon
upbringing,
very wholesome,
going to lab church.
And,
uh,
I joined the army when I was 17.
They have a program that allows you to
join like the reserves or the national
guard or the reserves while you're still
in high school.
Go to boot camp,
uh,
come back,
finish your senior year and then go back
and training and finish all your
advanced training.
Uh,
so that's what I did right after I
turned 17 in January and I hadn't listed
by February.
I enlisted the day after the ground war,
uh,
for the first Gulf war started.
And uh,
what I've always told people why I
joined,
which is the,
the most honest answer I can give you,
the why I joined is that I was 17 and
that's it.
It was the first adult decision that I
got to make.
I,
I grew up playing gi joe and stuff like
that.
So it's like a fun thing.
Like,
oh,
hey,
I can kind of,
you know,
be a boy scout or a kid for their
perpetually.
And that appealed to me.
So I joined.
Wow.
Can I haven't talked about this one in
the wild that,
that it was okay.
I'm from Utah.
Nothing happens in Utah and moved to New
York City in 2000.
The towers come down in September,
2001.
Um,
of course my initial reaction is one of
complete disbelief.
We live,
you know,
they say how sometimes you can look
right at something and not believe it.
Well,
that was the first time I've ever really
experienced that where I get a phone
call,
my buddy says,
hey,
the towers had been hit.
I'm like,
shut up asshole.
Don't come in for new.
Never again.
And don't tell me ridiculous crap like
that.
Come on.
Then I realized it's not kidding.
Um,
you know,
watching the news walk out to west
Broadway.
By the time I walked out to west
Broadway,
the first tower had already fell and I'm
looking right at where it was and I'm
not seeing it.
And it's like,
where's the tower?
I don't get it,
what happened?
I just,
I'm looking on that sky and I couldn't
and I didn't,
I could not process that.
The time I was in there,
I walk away to try and watch some news
and like,
ah,
maybe I should just watch it.
I go back a second time.
Now the second tower tower is fallen.
So I mean it's probably instead of
business lean of times,
uh,
the feeling of complete disbelief.
We were,
I,
I figured pretty much any national
guardsman in New York City at that time
knew they were going to get called up.
So we just all without being told,
started like congregating at our
respective armories and we were at
ground zero or near Ground Zero that
night.
The first two days we guarded,
uh,
an area a few blocks away,
you know,
from the sites.
And then by the third day,
the third week of the 11th day,
so I guess it was like a 20 seconds.
Uh,
we just did what we do as soldiers,
which is guard stuff.
We'd work 12 hour shifts.
Uh,
my platoon in particular,
it was stationed between buildings four
and five and all we did was guard.
We set up a perimeter,
um,
around a big,
and our job was to simply screen who
came in to the whole,
the fire.
The fire chief was in charge of the site
and he would tell us,
okay,
here I'm going to own the ironworkers in
or only let in ems world was the dogs.
And that's what we did.
And just kind of said their garden stuff
and told people who didn't have the
correct authorization from the fire
chief to fuck off.
Which was actually kind of interesting
because anyone who has a suit or badge
or anything was down there to include
FBI,
CIA,
Nsa,
guys like,
you know,
every,
everyone showed up there was
firefighters came from a Minnesota
wanting to help and we had to turn away,
which was kind of heartbreaking.
Um,
and that was her job is to kind of guard
a big hole.
There was some kind of unscrupulous
stuff that I think a lot of people don't
love talking about.
And uh,
looting was a bit of that.
Uh,
it's,
it's hard to thing about it because it's
not,
when we think about a ground zero and
nine 11,
and all the incredibly heroic things
that took place that day and the amount
of the outpouring of,
basically it was love that came from the
people who were in the army.
We have just kids in the lower east side
go running around with like doughnut
carts,
giving us donuts just because they want
to.
And it was all these wonderful stories.
But then there's also the storage to
have I like,
but there was a soldier in my,
you know,
one of the,
one of our soldiers had found like a box
of money and he didn't think that didn't
even cross his mind that it was wrong to
dilute it.
He ended up getting kicked out of the
army or just being an idiot.
There were some,
I know there were some problems too with
people who are in positions of trust,
who were taking advantage of the fact
that a lot of,
like the stores,
especially in the basements,
uh,
of the World Trade Center are now broken
and unguarded.
Um,
and I think that's really kind of a sore
spot for a lot of people.
I don't know how I details some,
I'm being kind of careful about what I
say about it,
but there were some problems with that
and I,
it was handled.
And hopefully that's kind of the end of
it.